what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have an update on the
Fantastic forecast this has been a hot
subject recently because it looks like
Marvel Studios is trying to finalize who
the cast is going to be and to top it
all off it looks like they're trying to
finalize who the cast is going to be
before San Diego Comic-Con which starts
July 19th so they are two months away
from San Diego Comic-Con which basically
gives them two months to cast the
official Fantastic Four and this also
includes the villain or villains of the
movie it does sound like Galactus is
indeed going to be the villain but he is
going to have Heralds yes not just one
but possibly two we do have Front
Runners for Galactus right now but
mainly Marvel Studios just needs to
announce the main cast of the actual
Fantastic Four team they don't really
need to announce the villains but Marvel
Studios and Kevin feige knows we've all
been waiting and we've all been been
talking about and we've all heard who
they met with already and really want to
know who our cast is going to be and
based off of the things that we've heard
Marvel Studios has a huge announcement
prepared for San Diego Comic-Con widely
believed to be the Fantastic Four now a
couple of days ago I did a video about
what to expect as far as a phase 6
announcement at San Diego Comic-Con so
you can check that out we'll link that
down below and put that in the pin
comment as well but basically expect a
phase six reveal we only had a part of
it at San Diego Comic-Con last year just
the Fantastic Four Avengers Secret Wars
and Avengers King Dynasty also side note
according to Insider Jeff Snyder he is
stating that this is a rumor but he was
hearing that the screenwriter Jeff
loveness who was writing Avengers King
Dynasty is now off of the project no
longer writing that movie and he does
claim that this happened before the
writers strike so if this is true right
now Avengers King Dynasty does not have
a writer however I have spoken to
Michael Waldron several times very
recently and if you're not familiar he
wrote the first season of Loki
Multiverse of Madness and he is writing
Secret Wars and he said that him and
Jeff loveness are super close because
they've written with each other before
in the past a lot and are kind of
working together for Kang Dynasty and
secret War so I hope that this isn't
true but if it is right now we have no
writer but going back to the Fantastic
Four in Marvel Studios needing to cast
the main family before two months we do
have an update and it seems like we
might have our thing also some news
about Sue storm but more on that in just
a bit but Insider my time to shine hello
has stated it's true David Diggs is in
talks for the thing in Fantastic Four
didn't it work out with Mila Kunis now
some time ago a couple of weeks ago a
month ago my time to shine hello stated
that Mila Kunis was in talks to play the
thing and to this day I'm not really
sure if that was a joke or if that was
an actual thing that Marvel Studios was
considering obviously we know and have
pictures of Mila Kunis meeting with Matt
shackman the director of the Fantastic
Four movie we heard that she was meeting
with Marvel as well talking to them
about a possible role with the Fantastic
Four we all assumed Sue storm but could
Marvel have possibly been thinking of
gender swapping the thing I don't think
that's the route they're going to go
especially since my time to shine hello
is stating that David Diggs is possibly
going to be the thing so I would
basically just get Mila Kunis out of
your head for the Fantastic Four if
anything she might play Sue storm
however based off of what we've heard
and we'll talk about that in a bit
that's not gonna happen but David digs
for the role of the thing I think would
actually work and it's rumored that
Marvel Studios did want a Jewish person
to play Ben Grim because Ben Grimm is
Jewish in the comics and David Diggs is
Jewish in fact David is the Hebrew
pronunciation of David and David means
beloved in Hebrew so that works for him
as far as what Marvel Studios wants Also
let's not forget that he is in The
Little Mermaid which is about to come
out so he's already already worked with
Disney which of course owns Marvel so
they already have their connection with
him established they've already worked
with him and they know that they can
work with him he's okay to work with
he's not a menace to work with now most
people know him from Hamilton but if you
take a look at some of his other movies
like blind spotting or his other shows
like snow piercer you can see that he's
got a lot of range and he can be really
really tough which is what you need for
the thing but he can also do some pretty
heartwarming stuff as well which is also
something that you need from the thing
so as far as choices for the thing are
concerned we've heard David Diggs now
we've heard Seth Rogen who is also
Jewish and Jason Segal who is also
Jewish as well now keep in mind the
person's actual body type doesn't really
matter because they're either just gonna
mocap it or put an actual thing suit on
the actor I've said this before but Mark
Ruffalo isn't jacked he's not big like
the Hulk it's all mocap so what really
matters here is one how the person will
obviously look as Ben Grimm and not the
actual little thing but two their acting
skills and I think any of these three
actors that I just mentioned all have
the chops to be able to play the thing
so I think as far as the things
concerned we're pretty good and Adam
Driver is apparently our Mr Fantastic
since some insiders have come out and
announced that we haven't heard anything
else that's contradictory to that so
Adam Driver seems to be locked in as Mr
Fantastic we haven't really heard much
about Johnny Storm except the fact that
some actors have passed on the role but
Sue storm we have heard so much about
and according to Insider Jeff Snyder
they did offer the role of Sue storm to
an actress but she turned it down that
actress was Emma Stone according to him
they offered her the role but she wanted
a big paycheck that Marvel Studios did
not want to give her now I love Emma
Stone I do I'm a fan of a lot of her
work however I don't think I would
choose her for Sue storm out of all of
the people that we've heard that could
possibly play Sue storm I would take
Vanessa Kirby Jody Comer Emily Blunt and
even Mila Kunis over her not because I
don't like her but I think they would
fit the role better plus I think I would
always see her as MJ and yes if Margot
Robbie were to play Sue storm I would
kind of see Harley Quinn there but since
that's a different franchise I think
it's a little bit different for me I
think that might be a little
hypocritical but it is what it is and
again I love Emma Stone I love a lot of
the movies and work that she's done but
I think for me right now Jody Comer and
Vanessa Kirby are at the top of the list
for me especially if you consider the
fact that Jody Comer has already worked
with Adam Driver before so that would
mean our Mr Fantastic and our Invisible
Woman already have worked together and
already have chemistry together and know
what it's like to work with each other
so that would be pretty simple and could
make for some great chemistry on screen
which of course is what you need in a
married couple because based off of what
some insiders have said when we see the
Fantastic Four in the MCU for the first
time they're going to be the Fantastic
Four team already and Sue and Reed are
going to be married already and possibly
even have kids already so the chemistry
between Mr Fantastic sick and the
invisible woman has to be there now as
far as the best friendship between Reed
and Ben I think Adam Driver and David
Diggs could work I could totally picture
them being best friends but going back
to sue even Grace Randolph tweeted today
seems Sue storm isn't as locked as we
feared come on Vanessa Kirby that is one
of my top picks too Grace and maybe
she's referring to the fact that
according to Jeff Snyder Emma Stone was
offered the Roll But turned it down
perhaps that's who they thought was
going to be playing Sue storm and that
it was all locked in but then it fell
through so if you have a Top Choice for
Sue's storm in the Fantastic Four film
let us know your thoughts down below
right now what we've heard again is
Margot Robbie Vanessa Kirby Jody Comer
Mila Kunis of course and if you have
anybody else that you think would do a
better job let us know your thoughts
down below also don't forget to like the
video and subscribe and leave a comment
so you can enter a giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox series X a PS4 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items we
pick a winner at the end of each month
and the winner gets to pick what they
want also we now have a full website up
that we post to every single day we also
have a patreon account up and a Discord
we'll link all of those in the pin
comment and in the description and of
course you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as well as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf
foreign